OF ROE V. WADE.
>> CNN LEGAL ANALYST JOINS US
NOW.
JOAN, YOU'VE COVERED THE COURT
FOR 25 YEARS.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN MULTIPLE BOOKS
ON THE COURT, INCLUDING CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS.
WHAT IS YOUR INITIAL REACTION TO
THIS?
>> MY INITIAL REACTION IS THAT
IT'S STUNNING ON SO MANY LEVELS.
FIRST OF ALL, JUST FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT 50 YEARS OF
PRECEDENT THAT IT APPEARS NOW
WILL DEFINITELY BE THROWN OUT
THE WINDOW.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE UNITED
STATES WAS ALREADY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF THE COURT
AND PUBLIC OPINION OF THE COURT
IN THIS MOMENT AS ABORTION
RIGHTS ARE BEING DISSOLVED
NATIONWIDE, APPEAR TO BE BEING
DISSOLVED NATIONWIDE.
AND FRANKLY, A LOT OF WHAT'S IN
THIS OPINION DOES JIVE WITH WHAT
I'VE BEEN HEARING MYSELF IN MY
REPORTING.
ALTHOUGH I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT WE HAVE NOT AUTHENTICATED
THIS DOCUMENT OURSELVES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF IT
RINGS TRUE WITH WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TOLD ALREADY.
BUT TO HAVE IT COME OUT THIS
WAY, TO HAVE THIS FIRST DRAFT --
AND TYPICALLY IT'S ONE OF MANY
DRAFTS THAT WILL BE AMENDED
THROUGH THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S ABOUT TO
SAIL THROUGH AT LEAST FIVE
JUSTICE -- PROBABLY JUST FIVE
JUSTICES -- READY TO OVERTURN
ROE V. WADE.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE WHO LIKELY WAS
NOT PART OF THAT VOTE BECAUSE
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT THE
CHIEF WAS READY TO UPHOLD THE
MISSISSIPPI LAW THAT WAS A BAN
ON ABORTIONS AFTER 15 WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY, THAT HE HAD THE
MAJORITY FOR THAT PART OF IT, AI
SIX-JUSTICE MAJORITY.
BUT HE IS NOT WITH WHAT APPEARS
TO BE SAMUEL ALITO WRITING FOR A
FIVE-JUSTICE MAJORITY THAT WOULD
BE SAMUEL ALITO, CLARENCE
THOMAS, AND THE THREE NEW
APPOINTEES OF PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
AGAIN, THIS IS WHAT POLITICO WAS
REPORTING AS PART OF THIS DRAFT.
BUT, AS I SAY, THIS ALL RINGS
VERY TRUE AND VERY TROUBLING.
AND FOR THE CHIEF JUSTICE TO SEE
THIS CASE AT THIS MOMENT UNFOLD
PUBLICLY LIKE THIS, I THINK
THAT -- I'M SURE HE WILL TRY TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF HOW THIS
ALL HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS WAS LEAKED,
WHETHER IT WAS LEAKED.
IT WAS REALLY IN THE INTEREST OF
NO ONE OF THE NINE JUSTICES TO
HAVE IT COME OUT LIKE THIS.
THE CONSERVATIVES APPARENTLY
HAVE WON.
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO HAVE IT COME
OUT LIKE THIS.
IT WOULD COME OUT AT THE END OF
JUNE.
THAT'S WHEN THE LAW WOULD BE
CHANGED, WHEN ABORTION RIGHTS,
YOU KNOW FROM 1973 WOULD BE
ROLLED BACK.
IT WOULD NOT BE IN THE INTEREST
OF THE THREE LIBERALS WHO, I'M
SURE, ARE DISSENTING VIGOROUSLY.
WE DON'T KNOW YET WHETHER THE
FIRST DRAFTS FROM THE CENTERS
HAD BEEN CIRCULATED BECAUSE ALL
WE HAVE IS APPARENTLY THIS ONE
FIRST DRAFT FOR THE MAJORITY.
SO, THERE'S SO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW JUSTICE
ALITO'S COLLEAGUED WOULD BE
REACTING TO THIS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, ANDERSON, THIS
WAS THE BIGGEST CASE OF THIS
TERM, THE BIGGEST CASE OF THE
DECADE IN SOME WAYS.
AND TO HAVE IT BURST FORTH ON
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC LIKE T